bienvenidos al vídeo sobre la
introducción de las ecuaciones
diferenciales y qué es una ecuación
diferencial bueno hemos hecho algunas
cosas como si yo dijera digamos que es
igual a no sé 3x por ejemplo si tomamos
la derivada de ambos lados de la de esta
e igualdad tendremos que la derivada de
y respecto de x es igual a 3
tomamos derivada de ambos lados pero
aquí podríamos usar una notación
diferencial verdad estamos tomando de ya
que es una diferencial del dx es una
diferencial de x qué significan estos
realmente son pequeñísimos cambios
infinite infinitesimales tanto en como
en x verdad en realidad una diferencial
es justamente una diferencia en el
cambio de las pendientes verdad tenemos
que una pendiente era la diferencia de
yes entre la diferencia de x verdad y
que cuando éstos se aproximan a 0 verdad
entonces eso era lo que era una derivada
esencialmente una diferencial es
infinitamente pequeño así que que es una
ecuación diferencial bueno es una
ecuación que incluye diferenciales así
que vamos a hacer este primer ejemplo
para resolverlo de iu entre de x es
igual a x al cuadrado más 1 muy bien
vamos a resolver cómo resolvemos esta
ecuación diferencial bueno hay varios
modos de hacerlo tú dice oh vaya esto
puede ser lo mismo que f prima de x y
sabemos que pues si tomamos una anti
derivada resolveríamos la ecuación así
puedes manipular estas derivadas verdad
vamos ahora a suponer que estos son como
números que de jay de x son como
numeritos y multiplicamos ambos lados de
esta ecuación por de x entonces tú
tienes digamos para un cambio muy
pequeño y belle es igual o tú tienes x
cuadrada más uno que multiplica a un
cambio pequeño en x es decir a está de x
otra forma de decirlo es que un cambio
muy pequeño en x
te permite saber cuál es el cambio en
verdad
de esta forma multiplicando por equis
cuadrada más uno bueno ahora tomemos la
anti derivada de los dos lados
o la integral de ambos lados verdad si
ya has visto los vídeos de integración y
la integral definida y el área y las
curvas te darás cuenta que una integral
es esencialmente una suma verdad es una
suma infinita de un montón de estos
infinitos pequeños leyes entonces si
tomas las sumas de todos los cambios en
leyes si tomas esa suma te quedas con
una y ahí te sugiero que vuelvas a
checar todos los vídeos que hicimos en
integración así que qué nos queda esto
es esencialmente la integral indefinida
de x cuadrada más 1 que es la anti
derivada de esto y cuál es la anti
derivada de x cuadrada más 1 bueno es x
al cubo entre 3 que la anti derivada de
x cuadrada
verdad y te recomiendo otra vez que veas
esos vídeos de anti derivadas creo que
hay como 8 no después sumamos x que es
la anti derivada de 1 y le sumamos una c
y de dónde viene bueno realmente viene
de una constante que al derivar la se
hace 0 y no aparecen en el integrando de
acá arriba verdad de ahí viene esta
constante entonces esta es la solución
general de la ecuación diferencial de
acá arriba porque y esto es algo muy
interesante así que con ecuaciones
tradicionales digamos la solución era un
numerito verdad si yo te dijera que ya
es igual a y es igual a 2 -1 entonces
tendremos restando y 2 y perdón de ambos
lados que menos y es igual a menos 1 que
es igual a 1 entonces esta es una
ecuación tradicional y tu solución fue
un único valor resolviste para la
variable verdad las ecuaciones
diferenciales son muy diferentes las
soluciones de hecho una función estás
diciendo que función satisface esta
ecuación diferencial y eso es algo que
hay que tener en mente en este momento
vamos a tener
por ejemplo otras cosas cuando tengamos
ecuaciones diferenciales parciales yo
creo que incluso valdría una valdría la
pena ser una lista de vídeos
introductorios a cualquier curso que
verías en la universidad de ecuaciones
diferenciales pero lo importante es que
la ecuación de estas perdón la solución
de estas ecuaciones no es un número sino
una una función y si quieres una
solución particular alguien te tiene que
dar condiciones iniciales o que te dé
puntos donde la función
pasa y después sustituimos para saber
cuál es esta constante ok entonces
digamos que permiten cambiar de colores
digamos que para esta ecuación nos dicen
que cuando y es igual a uno que vale 1
perdón cuando x es igual a 1 o se hace
en x igual a 1 llévale uno como
encontrarían esto bueno entonces si es
igual a 1 sustituyó 1 es igual a 1 al
cubo entre 3 que es un tercio verdad
uno más uno más está constante y
entonces despejamos la constante y que
nos queda cancelamos los unos de ambos
lados restamos un tercio de ambos lados
y nos queda que se es igual a menos un
tercio así que cuando usamos estas
condiciones que es un punto por donde
pasa la función ahora podemos determinar
una sola solución particular para esta
ecuación diferencial y que es ye igual a
x al cubo entre 3 más x menos un tercio
verdad ya no ponemos es sino un tercio
eso es para nuestra hace particular y si
no me creen tomé en esta expresión y
deriva en la respecto de x sustituyan en
esta ecuación diferencial y van a ver
que la igualdad es válida así tendrán
ustedes este verán que su derivada es x
cuadrada más 1 ahora hagamos otro
ejemplo
hagamos otro ejemplo este nos dice es un
poco más interesante dice que la
derivada de y respecto de x
es igual a x sobre y ok entonces esto es
interesante porque tiene allí del lado
derecho verdad y vamos a ponerle
condiciones que es igual a 1 en x igual
a 1 o sea o sea que cuando x es igual a
1 lleva ligada valga 1 vamos a buscar la
solución y esto es interesante porque
tenemos allí del lado derecho así que
esto puede ser como si lo tuviéramos de
haber hecho alguna diferenciación
implícita pero veamos a dónde nos lleva
así que hagamos lo mismo
digamos multipliquemos a ambos lados de
la ecuación x de x y obtenemos de y es
igual a x sobre de su x sobre x de x y
ahora multiplicamos de ambos lados
entonces que nos queda nos queda ya por
de y es igual a x x de x verdad
ahora podemos tomar la integral en ambos
lados de la ecuación o tomar la anti
derivada en ambos lados con respecto a x
verdad con respecto a x del lado derecho
y con respecto a del lado izquierdo no
sé por qué lo hice con café pero bueno
cuál es la anti derivada del lado
izquierdo pues esto es de cuadrada sobre
2 muy bien y podría decir más verdad
puedo agregar una constante déjenme
déjenme hacer eso podría haber una
constante aquí que la voy a llamar c1 c1
no sabemos cuál es esa constante y esto
es igual a la anti derivada de x que es
x cuadrada entre 2 más otra constante 0
cierto muy bien
ok o alguna otra constante no importa
tal vez sea el mismo número no lo sé no
conocemos ninguna de estas constantes
así que podríamos reescribir lo veamos
qué podríamos hacer permítanme poner
todo lo que tiene x del lado izquierdo y
así tendríamos ya cuadrada sobre 2 menos
- x cuadrada sobre 2 y esto es igual
hace 2 - en uno verdad pasándola hace
uno del otro lado y me queda ce 2 - c 1
que pues realmente
como no conocemos ninguna de estas dos
verdad no la sabemos entonces podríamos
decir que es cualquier constante así que
la resta de constantes que no sabemos
cuáles son pues es una tercera constante
arbitraria que le voy a llamar c así que
la solución general a esta ecuación
diferencial es cuadrada sobre 2 - x
cuadrada sobre 2 igual a c dicho hagamos
algo más sólo para limpiar esta esta
expresión
así que multiplicamos de ambos lados por
2 y obtendremos ya cuadrada menos equis
cuadrada es igual a 12 bueno ahora
sabemos que si se es cualquier número
constante podremos poner que ya cuadrada
menos equis cuadrada es igual a cero
llegó realmente 12 son otra constante
que vamos a llamarle c ahora usamos las
condiciones iniciales para saber quién
es esa así que cuando ya es igual a 1
tenemos
1 - 1 es igual a c verdad porque es
igual a 1 y x es igual a 1 así que uno
menos uno es cero por lo tanto se es
igual a cero así que la la solución
particular a esta ecuación diferencial
la voy a poner en verde es ya cuadrada -
x cuadrada igual a 0 o podríamos sumar x
cuadrada de ambos lados y tenemos de
cuadrada igual a x cuadrada ok ahora
ustedes podrían estar tentados a sacar
la raíz cuadrada en ambos lados y decir
que es igual a x xi pero hay que tener
cuidado la razón de que esto no sea así
tan preciso es porque x podría ser por
ejemplo menos dos menos dos y que podría
ser 2 o viceversa verdad entonces esto
podría satisfacer la ecuación pero no
está de acá arriba así que tengan
cuidado cuando tomen la raíz cuadrada
deben preocuparse por él más o menos
hagamos otro ejemplo
digamos
esta dice que la derivada de y con
respecto de x es igual a ok esto es
todavía más interesante fíjense es es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de x sobre ella
muy bien así que
esto dice que
aunque las condiciones iniciales van a
ser igual a 4x igual a 1 sale podríamos
hacer esto de manera similar así que
hagamos el mismo paso multiplicamos
ambos lados por de equis y entonces
queda de y es igual a solo para
ahorrarnos un paso voy a reescribir esto
como raíz de x sobre la raíz de i y
multiplique dijimos por de x ahora
multipliquemos ambos lados de esta
ecuación x raíz de iu y que tendremos
voy a reescribir la como real a un medio
que es la raíz cuadrada x de ella que es
igual a x a la un medio de x
recordemos que elevar al a un medio es
sacar raíz cuadrada verdad y cuál es la
anti derivada de y elevada a la un medio
bueno pues esto es sumarle uno al
exponente y luego dividir entre el
exponente que me quedó así que uno más
un medio son tres medios
dividido entre tres medios o lo que es
lo mismo multiplicar por dos tercios
correcto es lo mismo y si no están
seguros de esto porque a veces pues
puede ser algo un poco confuso esto de
las fracciones tomen la derivada si
derivamos es tres medios por los dos
tercios que es uno y luego a tres medios
le restamos uno en el exponente y me
queda un medio verdad ahora sumamos su
constante y la anti derivada de x sala
un medio es dos tercios de x a la tres
medios más otra constante ahora que
podemos hacer bueno
tomamos pasamos la x del lado izquierdo
de esta ecuación y obtenemos dos tercios
de iu a la tres medios menos dos tercios
de x a la tres medios igual hace 2 - c 1
que reescribimos como una constante c ok
así multiplicamos ambos lados por tres
medios estos se hacen uno algo se
cancelan y tenemos ya la tres medios
menos equis a la tres medios igual a
tres medios por c pero tres medios por
cualquier constante sigue siendo
constante así que lo dejamos como sé
espero que esto no los confundan mucho
tres medios porque no lo conocía
realmente podríamos llamarle hasta hace
tres ya estás de cuatro pero bueno no
importa vamos a determinar esta sea a
través de nuestras condiciones iniciales
que nos dicen que ya en vale cuatro y
equis vale 1 es decir
tomamos la solución particular de esta
ecuación diferencial determinando
nuestras de verdad y entonces 4 elevado
a la 3 medios
menos 1 elevado a la 3 medios es igual
hace cuánto es 4 elevado a la tres
medios bueno es 4 a la un medio que es 2
y al cubo es 8 menos 1 a la 3 medios que
es la raíz cuadrada de 1 es uno y
elevado al cubo es 1 así que tenemos
menos uno es igual a c de donde
concluimos que ese es igual a 7 así que
la solución particular de esta ecuación
diferencial nos lo haré de otro color y
es
es ya elevado a la tres medios y elevado
a la tres medios
- x elevado a la tres medios y esto debe
ser igual a 7